All right, let's get into audience questions for
the week. First one is about the one point nine
trillion dollar coronavirus stimulus bill. And
there's a bunch of versions of this going around.
But the question is, why are all
of these right wingers saying
that most of the one point nine dollars trillion
has nothing to do with coronavirus if it's a
coronavirus relief bill? Now, this isn't true.
We're going to go through what is in this bill
and actually talk about the origins of this claim
that most of the money isn't for covid stimulus,
but this is not a new claim from Republicans.
They did the exact same thing with Hurricane
Sandy, Hurricane Sandy when it hit New York
and New Jersey years ago. I think it was 2012.
The response bill contained not only money
to fix the damage that happened, but also
because American infrastructure is woefully
outdated and because we haven't elected
a system of elected government that doesn't
incentivize thinking proactively spending now
to prevent a problem in the future
that will cause us to spend more money.
We are in the unfortunate situation
where sometimes in order to get things
fixed and prevent future problems, you have to do
it when a system breaks and you have a problem.
With Hurricane Sandy, you saw that there was a
bunch of money in the Hurricane Sandy relief bill,
which people like Ted Cruz referred to as
pork, and there was some pork, but a lot of it
was not that meant to strengthen infrastructure.
When you look at the flooding that took place,
when you look at the breakdown of all sorts of
different resources and infrastructure at that
time, the idea was, hey, we now have evidence
that because we didn't strengthen this stuff,
because it's so not robust, it's so fragile when
we have a situation like a hurricane that hits
an area that less frequently gets hurricanes,
New York and New Jersey, all this stuff breaks.
So as part of recovering, let's also strengthen
things for the future. OK, with that framework,
the meme that's been going around is, well, hold
on a second. If each American, not everybody,
but most Americans get fourteen hundred
bucks and then you get some money for kids,
you'll see it floating around that only a few
hundred billion of the one point nine trillion
is for covid. This is so silly. But because it's
being repeated so much, it's worth understanding
that in the one point nine trillion you have, for
example, one hundred and sixty billion for vaccine
purchases, distribution, injection, as well as
covid testing. That's covid related. It's not
cash for people, but the more we vaccinate, the
the faster we do away with this pandemic and the
more the economy will recover. Come on, guys.
You're saying that's not actually for covid?
Three hundred and sixty billion for state and
local governments to make sure that they are
solvent, solvent? Many states, because of the
when you have a reduction in business activity,
states where those businesses exist
taken reduced tax revenue, the states
still hopefully are providing police, fire,
school, you know, all this different stuff. So
as a result of coronavirus, a bunch of different
states need money. You're really going to say
that's not coronavirus related, eight and a
half billion for rural hospitals to stay open.
And of course, those are going to be
important vaccination sites in rural areas,
25 billion to fund child care centers that
you're going to say that has nothing to do with
coronavirus. One of the issues we have right
now is many parents can't get back to work.
If their kids aren't back in school, so you very
quickly start to understand why funding childcare,
which, by the way, we don't fund enough in this
country anyway, is related to coronavirus 15
billion to subsidize child care for essential
workers. We need our essential workers to be
working. They need to be working to make money.
But if they have to be taking care of their kids,
they can't work and then they can't put food on
their family's table. This is it's coronavirus
related. Why are we in this situation, 130 billion
for K through 12 schools to reopen and decrease
class sizes. It costs money to decrease class
sizes to open safely. If you decrease class sizes,
you either need additional teachers to have way
more classes or you need to be paying overtime.
If teachers are going to be doing two sessions,
however you're going to do it, it's going to cost
money. People on the right wants schools open.
People on the left want schools open safely.
Here's money. In order to do that, we could go
on and on and on, you know, 15 billion dollars to
prevent airline layoffs. OK, there are some who
are saying airlines should be allowed to fail.
Unfortunately, er er fortunately or unfortunately,
whatever the case may be, airlines are a big
piece of infrastructure, transportation
infrastructure. You could make the case,
let them fail, but we're going to be depending on
airlines if and when things start to improve, to
allow commerce and allow travel to restart
travel, one of the hardest hit industries.
So, you know, you can make a case on any of
these things. Well, maybe the 15 should be 12
or something like that. But the
talking point that's floating around
is most of the money has nothing to
do with coronavirus. And of course,
that is completely and totally untrue. This
isn't a new talking point from the right,
and it's not at all surprising that they're
rehashing it and reviving it right now.